the easiest way to find documentation is
to search for it looking through the CSS
for bootstrap we can find documentation
around containers the grid system which
you'll be using later different media
queries that bootstrap uses to ensure
that your site looks good on whatever
size screen it's open on and it even
gives you different options for types of
columns let's take a look at these
predefined classes I want you to check
out the documentation for the predefined
classes when you're done you should be
able to answer the following questions
and apply the correct classes to your
HTML which classes should use to wrap
the first row of portfolio items the
first row would be like this following
the blue box around a pie and sunflower
and which class would you use to wrap
one featured portfolio item like simply
just a pie type your answers in here